سالنا الناس في مصر كيف تقضي وقتك
الازدحاب المروريه
[موسيقى]
نتماشى مع الزحام المروري بسمع مثلا اذاعه
القران الكريم
والحمد لله اليوم بيعدي يعني
بتكلم مع والدتي مع اخواتي فتعلمت ان انا
دايما معايا
السبحه بتاعتي
وبذكر بذكر الله بقى بكل اسماء الحسنى
الكتيره التي لا تعظم تعد ولا تحصى والله
عادي بقى
الراديو وصلنا نسمع حاجه اغنيها حلوه
بتاعه
[موسيقى]
تبقى فتره بتبقى ممله بس الواحد بيفضل
اللي هو مثلا ممكن يقرا مثلا عناوين عن
مثلا عن الرياضه او مثلا ممكن يعني يسمع
قران او اي حاجه مهمه الواحد يقضوا وقت
اللي هو يطلع من الهم اللي هو بيبقى في
الوقت بتاع المرور ده وانا في الزحمه بمسك
التليفون باتسلى اخش على الواتس افتح
الانستا ببجي الكلام دوت اسمع مزيكا
الكلام دوت انا بصراحه انا بحكم ان انا
معايا يعني موتوسيكل ف ساعات بطلع
الموبايل امسك الموبايل شويه اكلم واحد
صاحبي كده يعني اكيد بمسك الموبايل اكثر
من كده
[موسيقى]